we have a full operation in ukraine our
embassy is operating and doing all the
work it needs to do but it's important
that we prepare for any eventuality and
there are very worrying signs about what
could happen the uk is absolutely the
forefront
of providing support to ukraine
in terms of defensive weapons
in terms of supporting ukraine with
economics and trade and also we have a
very strong package of sanctions ready
should
russia stage an incursion into ukraine
you just come back from australia given
all that's been going on over the last
week do you think you were in the wrong
hemisphere when all this was happening
what we are facing is a serious global
issue
of aggressors seeking to advance
and challenge freedom and democracy and
it's very important we work with all our
allies
around the world because if there was
an incursion into ukraine
that would have implications not just
for europe but also more widely globally
just on
what you released over the weekend about
russia trying to set up a puppet
government in ukraine what was the basis
of that intelligence where did it come
from well i can't go into the details of
how we procure our intelligence the
reason we put that out into the public
domain is we are going to call out
every instance of russia trying to
influence democracy trying to subvert
ukraine false flag operations and
sabotage and we will call that out
and just quickly finally on this area do
you think germany should ever turn on
nordstrom 2.
i am very very concerned about europe's
energy dependence on russian gas
and i'm very clear
that lordstream 2 should not go ahead in
the event of an incursion
into ukraine should it ever go ahead
as i said i would like to see europe
reduce its dependency on russian gas
on to brexit today's talks has there
been
any progress at all with the eu
well there has been progress we've had
constructive discussions and i'm
absolutely determined to protect
political stability
and peace in northern ireland i want to
work constructively
with the eu to be able to achieve that
and we need to do it in short order
we've agreed to have more intensive
talks i'll be catching up with maril
cechovich next week
and we want to make progress we believe
there is a deal to be done you say
there's been progress where in what
areas i'm not going to provide a running
commentary to the media because i don't
think that's the best way of getting
this done but what i'm absolutely
determined to do is protect political
stability in northern ireland protect
peace in northern ireland and get this
done
end of february is being talked about as
a possible deadline for these talks is
that right
as i've said we need to make as much
progress as we can
in the next few weeks that's why we are
having intensive talks the situation uh
in northern ireland is very difficult
we want goods to be able to flow freely
that's why we need to make urgent
progress but would you pause the talks
for example as we approach the stormont
elections
i want to get this done so i'm not
putting any barriers on that we're
putting as much resources we can
into making this work and making things
happen for the people of northern
ireland and just finally
on
did you know about those allegations and
while an inquiry is happening do you
think the chief whip should be staying
in post
well i was very concerned to hear
what nazghani had to say it's obviously
very worrying allegations i'm pleased
the prime minister has ordered a cabinet
office inquiry to take place and i won't
make any further comment until we've had
the results of that inquiry